graduation day is reason to celebrate
for the latest group of recruits to make
it through basic training at Fort
Jackson South Carolina
this rite of passage once represented
the beginning of a career in the Army
but for a quarter of these graduates the
training actually started weeks before
basic let's go here we go
a Future Soldier Preparatory course
30-year-old istrabreg alhadi signed up
because she wanted a career change but
was worried about meeting the military's
Fitness requirements it's like an
introduction to boot camp so you lose
that
body fat for the Army standards and you
also learn your proper form working out
how to eat so it's a change in lifestyle
since piloting the program one year ago
the Army says more than ten thousand
recruits have taken advantage of it with
95 percent of them advancing to basic
training
more than one in four Americans qualify
rates many Americans aren't even
considering the military as an option
but this prep Force hopes to change the
numbers
there's academic help as well for those
looking to improve their scores on the
so-called ASVAB test that determines
which jobs in the military they qualify
for if I didn't do the prep course my
ASVAB score wouldn't have been as high
as if I took it in the civilian World
those in charge say with fewer Americans
wanting to enlist the military must
invest in those who do this program
is giving
to those that want to serve what they
need to become what we need in our
Fighting Force Major General Johnny
Davis oversees recruiting for the Army I
think we're in a real war for talent
because we want the very best to serve
in our nation uh and and we're competing
for that
private David Dean took the prep course
and lost 35 kilos before completing
basic training where he earned the title
team leader
it gave people like myself a chance to
do something where two years ago the
Army would have told me no but it
allowed me to come in give it my best
efforts
and actually show that I deserve to be
here
with the Army still struggling to meet
its quota for new soldiers it is making
the prep course a permanent part of its
training regimen Kristen salumi Al
Jazeera Fort Jackson South Carolina
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera